President Assad speaking there - Russian
television well one man who has
first-hand experience of conditions in
Syria is young a gallant UN advisor on
humanitarian access in Syria and head of
the Norwegian Refugee Council sir thank
you so much for coming to see us in
person let's first talk about a Aleppo
because we're basically running out of
words to describe the devastation that
the the carnage that's taking place
there and we have pictures running
behind us showing the latest there share
with us if you will your experience
you've been there yeah I was there
personally three-and-a-half years ago at
that time I saw parents digging for
their children in apartment buildings
that were leveled to the ground by this
enormous Scud missiles coming from a
government controlled area to the then
already opposition-held parts of Aleppo
these areas we where we thought it could
not be worse than it was at that time it
was February 9 2013 it's become worse
every single month
since that time so it's the Sarajevo of
our time and age it's a large city and
we see the slow death of this large city
it has to stop the only way out of this
is to end the bombardment to end the use
of violence that's what we would like to
see but at the same time we just heard
President Assad saying basically the key
to winning over the rest of the country
is taking over Aleppo and increasing the
offensive in the rest of the country how
worried are you by the prospect that we
could see a further ramping up of
military actions in the country of
course I'm I'm very afraid that that
they will present us that himself said
he believed there was a military
solution after five years of proving
there is no military solution he's still
saying that there's a portable Russia
the armed opposition groups are
supported by a host of other countries
there is no military solution we are
humanitarians we
see there is no military solution there
is not either a humanitarian solution
it's the political negotiated solution
to this it will continue and continue if
they only try military means alright so
are you encouraged by these crisis talks
that are going to take place this
weekend do you think do you hope they'll
achieve this political solution that
you're looking for well I'm hopeful I
mean the only way out is that Russia and
the US have joint leadership to guide us
out of this that Iran Saudi Arabia and
the Gulf countries who are also on each
side of this war stop bringing fuel to
the fire but help int us into political
negotiations and in the meantime we need
humanitarian access to the people we
haven't been able to reach eastern
aleppo with any significant aid since
the end of June the medical crisis could
not be worse the remaining six
functioning hospitals have nearly all of
them been bombed there our latest
figures I have are even worse than yours
well over 400 dead now well over 100
dead children well over 1,300 injured
were working around the clock now to try
to get evacuation of wounded get medical
supplies in and get even new personnel
more medical personnel in but was still
unsuccessful because the party are not
giving us the pause we need and the
fighting and all the permits we need to
entice deliver do you feel that the
international community as a whole has
failed the people of Syria absolutely
we've all failed
we'll all failed in this I feel very
strongly we failed the besieged areas of
Aleppo we've gotten more aid in this
year by far compared to last year but
then again the people are bombed every
day and night they are not content to
get blankets and
and a little bit more more food they
need an end to the bombardment these are
civilians here we have hospitals that
that are being targeted it's a war crime
to target hospitals and they have been
repeatedly targeted in eastern Aleppo
and by the way also by mortars coming
into West Aleppo which is government
controlled when we look back at Syria in
a decade 20 years from now what do you
think we'll say we'll say that we failed
just like we all agreed never again we
said after Trevor Aneesa and Sarajevo
and the so-called safe areas of Bosnia
that were anything but safe they were
death traps very many places and we will
see how diplomacy failed really we need
to have more good diplomats working even
harder with Russia and the United States
in the lead so yes I hope they will
succeed in in Lausanne because if not we
will be picking up the pieces in this
devastating Civil War it's interesting
you describe Aleppo as a death trap is
that how you see it
well yes I see especially Eastern Aleppo
now which is totally besieged it's
militarily encircled humanity is not a
humanitarian aid is not coming in
civilian population are not able to
escape so of course it's a it's a it's a
trap and how many people inside 275
thousand so the total number of people
in besieged areas now in in Syria is
well over 800 thousand the number of
people trapped like that has increased
this year thank you so much for coming
to see us in person thank you